beau sent me a sort of an update to the
systematically scammy nature of Donald
Trump's claims about charitable
donations
you might remember number one the
Washington Post did a really good
investigation into Trump's claimed
donations and his actually provable
donations and it appears as though he
only donated around ten thousand dollars
dating back to many many years very
contrary to the claims that Donald Trump
is made about charitable donations after
that happened Donald Trump actually did
a donation on stage at a campaign event
which appears to have possibly violated
a variety of different laws uh including
federal election law laws around
nonprofits and charitable giving
etcetera etcetera
we have now learned that the reality is
as are most things with Donald Trump way
worse than we thought it's more pathetic
than we thought it's more embarrassing
than we previously thought the
Washington Post's David Farenthold
reached out to many of the charities
that Donald Trump claims to have donated
to on his IRS submissions and said hey
Donald Trump says that he donated to you
did Donald Trump donate to you pretty
simple question and that Donald Trump
did not let me say it a different way
not only did Donald Trump not donate
recently to some of these organizations
according to many of them he has never
donated to them I will put up on the
screen for you here David Farenthold
tweet where you actually see his uh
notebook where he wrote down some of
these organizations and just started
calling them and you'll note that many
of them say never next to them the
Border Patrol foundation the New York
Pops the National Children's Dental
Foundation Alzheimer's community care
Trump says that he donated to these
organizations these organizations say no
we didn't know he didn't rather and if
you say well Trump doesn't really have a
track record of this you're wrong you
may not have heard but Donald Trump has
been forced to pay
$25,000 IRS fine over a twenty five
thousand dollar donation that his
foundation made it to Florida Attorney
General Pam Bondi before she as I've
told you conveniently drop that
investigation into Trump University in
that case Trump not only used is
supposedly Charitable Foundation to push
money to a political campaign he also
said that he was actually donating to a
charity which we now know never actually
got the money this is absolutely
despicable this is despicable on a
number of levels number one we're
learning more and more about how
although Donald Trump is accusing
Hillary Clinton of being involved in
pay-to-play he really is the guy who has
been involved in pay and pay to play
demonstrably and has actually been fined
for that but beyond that one of the
lowest things that you can do is to
claim that you were raising money for a
charity and you never actually give the
charity the money one of the lowest
things that you can do is claim that you
are giving a charity money and not
actually give them the money and this is
not the only time that Donald Trump has
done this Donald Trump has a very long
track record of number one claiming to
make donations that appear absolutely
nowhere in terms of the actual financial
records of these organizations but also
using this foundation as a way to curry
political capital think about it for a
second the primary purpose of the Trump
foundation is not charity it's sort of
the exact same thing Donald Trump is
done his entire life it's about
enriching himself and the sickest part
of it all and I know that there's some
people in the audience who just hate
Hillary Clinton so much they're not
going to this this example this analogy
is not going to resonate with them but
think about it Donald Trump has been
accusing Hillary Clinton of running a
pay to play scheme through the Clinton
Foundation where you donate to the
Clinton Foundation and then Hillary
Clinton as Secretary of State would meet
with you you would get favor
from the State Department or you would
get a contract or whatever we know that
for many many years Donald Trump gave no
money at all to his own foundation but
other people did and then the
Foundation's money was used for Trump's
personal business gain greasing the
wheels or whatever else the donors to
the Trump foundation are either number
one knowing that Donald Trump is
actually using this charity to curry
political favor and do deals and
whatever else if the donors to the trunk
foundation know that that's what he's
doing they are the ones who are
complicit in this pay-to-play if they
don't know that that's what Donald Trump
is doing with the money they are being
defrauded if you donated to the Donald J
Trump foundation with the idea that he's
really going to be helping all of these
great charities that he claims to be
helping and in reality he's been using
the money to make investigations about
Trump University go away he's been
putting donations on his IRS disclosures
without actually having made those
donations if I was a donor to the Trump
foundation and didn't realize that
that's what he was doing I would be
furious furious with Trump yet another
way in which Donald Trump accuses others
of doing exactly what it is that he is
actually doing and I wish I could say oh
well now his supporters are going to
figure out that this is what he's doing
and they're gonna be really really angry
probably not they really don't seem to
care